to present the next Oscars here's a
former winner herself we flew here from
New York where she's appearing in a
Broadway show night of the iguana miss
Shelly withers and the star the ben
casey show the very fine actor mr.
Benson Edwards
since we are involved in a medium which
more and more visually communicate
Kate's ideas as well as entertainment
our cameramen become more and more
important we actors like to say that a
good cameraman photographs our face a
great one our souls so Vincent and I
tonight are privileged to present the
awards for our great artists who are our
cinematographers well said chili the
nominees for the best cinematography of
a black-and-white picture
Edward Colman for the absent-minded
professor France F planner for the
children's our origin shootin for the
hustler Ernest Lazlo for judgment at
Nuremburg Daniel L Feb 4 one two three
and here's the envelope
dr. Casey will you perform the surgery
certainly dr. winners the winner wagon
shift on for the hustler
[ __ ] borrow against it
at the Olive you
on behalf of intership tonight more he
is tonight but I'm sure you'd like to
thank his gaffer and rest of his crew
and that he's probably very happy about
this
ladies and gentlemen I'm the world's
greatest gate crasher and I just came
here to present Bob Hope with his 1938
trophy er ba stand firm mr. Bob
the nominees for the best the nominee to
the Best Cinematography of a color
picture are Jack Cardiff bar fanny
Russell Mary for Flower Drum Song Harry
straddling senior from majority of one
Charles Lang jr. for one-eyed Jack's
Daniel L fat for West Side Story winner
is Daniel
graduates graduates I would like to
thank the Mary's company Bob white and
Jerry Robbins and particularly a good
crew thank you very much
who needs price waterhouse
while we needs a doorman